Hallo und herzlich Willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast über Raumfahrt und andere.
Kosmische Angelegenheiten.
Mein Name ist Tim Frithloff und ich begrüße alle hier zu Nummer 114 von Raumzeit.
Und ja, wie ihr schon gemerkt haben dürftet, gibt es ja hier eine ganze Serie
von Podcasts hier am CERN in Genf, wo wir mal aufschlüsseln wollen,
was denn hier eigentlich alles so installiert ist, warum und wie es funktioniert.
Und nachdem wir jetzt schon ein wenig über die Geschichte des CERNs gelernt
haben und auch so die Grundlagen der ganzen Physik,
die hier erforscht wird,
angerissen haben, uns auch schon den ersten Detektor angeschaut haben mit ALICE,
wollen wir heute mal so ein bisschen auf den Kern der Kernforschung hier kommen
und uns in einer Reihe von zwei Sendungen die Hauptdetektoren des LHC,
des Large Hadron Collider, anschauen, mit denen so der Großteil der Experimente durchgeführt wird.
Und fangen wir an mit dem CMS-Detektor, dem Compact Muon Solenoid, Toller Name, Detektor.
Ja und um darüber Auskunft zu erhalten, begrüße ich meinen Gesprächspartner,
nämlich Wolfgang Adam. Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo.
Herzlich willkommen bei Raumzeit. Du bist Senior Research Associate für CMS
Analyse und CMS Tracking und stellvertretender Sprecher.
Genau, ich arbeite für das Institut für Hochenergiephysik der Österreichischen
Akademie der Wissenschaften in Wien und habe eben gleichzeitig auch Funktionen
in der Kollaboration, die das CMS-Experiment betreibt.
Ja und wie bist du dazu gekommen mit der ganzen Wissenschaft?
War das irgendwie schon ein Kindheitstraum?
Naja ich hatte mich früher für Mathematik,
Technik, Physik interessiert und habe dann ein Studium der Physik an der Technischen
Universität in Wien begonnen und als es Richtung Diplom ging,
hatten wir einen Professor für Theoretische Physik,
der gleichzeitig zu dieser Zeit Präsident des CERN Councils war,
das heißt der Vertretung an der CERN-Mitgliedsstaaten, die die strategische
Ausrichtung des CERN sozusagen definieren.
Und er hat uns eben diese Art von Physik näher gebracht und von den Herausforderungen
gesprochen, die es hier gibt.
Und das hat mich natürlich interessiert habe mich dann für meine Diplomarbeit
beworben beim Institut für Hochenergiephysik,
das eben das Institut in Wien ist, das sich mit dieser experimentellen Hochenergiephysik
beschäftigt und bin dort eingestiegen in die Vorbereitung des Delphi-Experiments.
Das war der Beschleuniger, der hier im Tunnel vor dem LHC gelaufen ist,
LEP, Large Electron Positive Collider, und wir haben da eine Detektor-Komponente
in Wien gebaut und ich habe mich dann angefangen damit zu beschäftigen und bin
dann zum CERN gekommen um die Installation und den Betrieb und die Auslese dieses
Detektors zu übernehmen.
Das war ab dem Ende der 80er Jahre,
also LEP ist während der 90er Jahre gelaufen, Also die beginnen 1989.
Das heißt du bist jetzt hier seit 30 Jahren oder länger noch?
Ja. Ja.
Okay.
Und ich habe dann am CERN ein Fellowship gemacht, im selben Experiment,
aber in einem anderen Detektor, dem Cherenkov Detektor.
Das ist etwas, was wir hier CMS nicht finden,
aber das ist ein Detektor, mit dem man Geschwindigkeit geladener Teilchen
messen kann und sie damit identifizieren kann und habe
dann verschiedene Physikgruppen in Delphi übernommen und dann gegen Ende der
Lablaufzeit auch eine gemeinsame Arbeitsgruppe der vier Lab-Experimente für
Suchen nach unter Anführungszeichen exotischer Physik, also neuen Teilchen.
Exotische Physik. Tcherenkov-Strahlung war ja auch schon mal ein Thema,
Raumzeit 104, da war ich auf La Palma
und wir haben dort die Pläne für das Tcherenkov-Teleskop-Array angeschaut.
Das ist ja related, sagen wir mal, da kosmische Strahlung und so weiter.
Genau, nur entsteht dort die Tcherenkov-Strahlung in der Atmosphäre.
Da muss man nicht beschleunigen. Genau, während hier in den Hochenergiephysik-Experimenten
das innerhalb eines Detektors passiert.
Genau, aber das ist ja immer wieder auch schön zu sehen, so diese Analogie.
Auf der einen Seite gibt es halt die Installationen, die einfach versuchen die
kosmische Strahlung, die ohnehin schon beschleunigt durchs All schießt,
in irgendeiner Form auszuwerten.
Da wäre ja nebenbei auch noch das Alpha Magnetspektrometer zu erwähnen.
Hatte ich ja auch schon bei Raumzeit 38 schon vor 10 Jahren tatsächlich das
Thema schon mal, dessen Kontrollzentrum ja tatsächlich hier auch auf dem Zerngelände ist.
Genau, aber wie wir ja auch schon in den letzten drei Sendungen ausgeführt haben,
hier wird halt viel beschleunigt und durch diese Kaskade von Ringen kriegt man
dann halt einfach die Teilchen mit einer sehr sehr hohen Energie zu den Detektoren
und das ist dann eben sozusagen der Ort, wo es dann unter anderem mit dem CMS weitergeht.
Genau, und das hat natürlich auch Auswirkungen auf die Auslegung der Experimente,
weil wir eben hier nicht natürlich vorkommende Phänomene betrachten,
die über Zeit konstant beobachtet werden können, sondern wir generieren hier
die Kollisionen, die wir beobachten wollen, direkt.
Und das hat natürlich Auswirkungen auf, wie wir die Detektoren auslegen, betreiben.
Jetzt wollen wir nochmal sagen, also ich hab's ja schon angedeutet,
also CMS und Atlas, was, Spoiler Alert, das Thema in der nächsten Sendung sein
wird, das sind ja im Prinzip so...
Geschwister, Nachbarn, die kümmern sich im Wesentlichen um freundliche Konkurrenten.
Also zwei Detektoren mit unterschiedlicher Technik, die mehr oder weniger denselben Auftrag haben.
Im Prinzip in all dieser ganzen Beschleunigungen die selbe Art von Phänomenen
versuchen zu beobachten, aber eben mit unterschiedlicher Technik.
Und das finde ich einen ganz interessanten Ansatz, weil man ja dadurch sozusagen
von vornherein feststellt, okay, wir haben kein Bias in unserer Technologie bei dem, was wir sehen.
Oder zumindest nicht so weniger, weniger Bias.
Es gibt verschiedene Gründe natürlich, das so zu machen.
Warum wir überhaupt zwei Experimente haben, das hat mit dem zu tun,
was ich vorhin erwähnt habe, dass wir hier eben die Kollisionen selbst erzeugen.
Ein Grundsatz der Wissenschaft ist natürlich, dass Messungen immer kontrolliert,
unabhängig kontrolliert werden können von unabhängigen Wissenschaftlern.
Bei vielen Experimenten kann das hintereinander geschehen.
Also es wird ein Experiment durchgeführt, man findet etwas, danach kommt ein
anderes Experiment, das das überprüfen wird und verbessern wird.
Aber nachdem wir hier natürlich den Beschleuniger betreiben müssen,
ist es nicht optimal, wenn man die Messzeiten, die ja ohnehin Jahre und Jahrzehnte
dauern, wenn man die verdoppeln würde.
Und daher ist es viel ökonomischer, die zwei Experimente gleichzeitig zu betreiben.
Und für die unterschiedliche Auslegung gibt es verschiedene Gründe,
technologische Gründe, aber es gibt Es gibt vor allem unsere,
wenn wir Messungen durchführen, sind die Werte, die wir messen,
natürlich mit Fehlern behaftet.
Das heißt, es gibt da Unsicherheiten auf die Messwerte. Das ist vollkommen normal.
Das geschieht in allen Messungen.
Und diese Unsicherheiten können verschiedenen Ursprung haben.
Es gibt einen ganz einfachen statistischen Ursprung.
Das heißt, wir beobachten eine endliche Zahl von Ereignissen,
wenn wir einen bestimmten Prozess messen und dadurch können Fluktuationen auftreten.
Wenn man einen Würfel zehnmal würfelt, dann werden die Eins bis Sechs nicht
genau mit der gleichen Wahrscheinlichkeit auftreten.
Also man wird nicht die gleiche Zahl beobachten.
Ähnlich ist es hier, wenn wir nur eine bestimmte Zahl von gewissen Ereignissen
beobachten, dann kann diese Zahl einfach ganz natürlich rauf und runter fluktuieren.
Aber es gibt dann eine zweite Komponente, die wir hier typischerweise systematische
Fehler nennen. Das ist...
Mögliche Verzerrungen des Messwerts durch Effekte, die zum Beispiel aus dem
Detektor kommen können oder aus der theoretischen Modellierung dieser Prozesse.
Und um diese Fehler möglichst auszuschließen, ist es günstig,
wenn man zwei Experimente mit unterschiedlichem Aufbau hat, weil Detektorfehler
dann im anderen Experiment nicht in derselben Form auftreten würden und man
sich dadurch gegenseitig kontrollieren kann.
Ja, das ist sozusagen jetzt erstmal die Prämisse gewesen.
Das heißt die beiden Detektoren sind quasi mit unterschiedlichen Philosophien,
mit unterschiedlichen technischen Philosophien, aber eben mit dem selben Ziel entwickelt worden.
Was ich schon mal ganz bemerkenswert finde, weil das sind ja alles sehr komplexe
Maschinen. Also jede Maschine für sich ist ja schon sehr sehr sehr kompliziert
und auch so nie dagewesen.
Also so ein bisschen wie auch in der Raumfahrt, es ist eine permanente Prototypenentwicklung
und man baut ja nicht was, was man schon mal hatte, weil das kennt man ja schon,
ist ja auch langweilig so.
Und das verstehe ich auch sehr gut, das ist einer der Reize,
der hier sozusagen immer wieder ist. Man hat es halt einfach immer mit Bleeding
Edge Technology zu tun, mit anderen Worten, man muss aber diesen Aufwand dann
gleich zweimal treiben.
Und ist natürlich dann vielleicht auch versucht, in gewisser Hinsicht, Oh mein Gott.
Also dann steht man ja immer so in diesem Spannungsfeld, machen wir es jetzt
überall komplett anders aus Prinzip oder tendieren wir dann dazu zu wenig auf
abgehangener Technologie zu basieren,
die dann auch so viel Risiko mit in das Ding reinbringt, dass es eben vielleicht
am Ende nicht funktioniert?
Die Auslegung dieser Experimente ist immer eine Balance zwischen einem Kompromiss
zwischen wirklich die neueste und beste Technologie zu verwenden und gleichzeitig
das Risiko klein zu halten.
Das Kleinhalten des Risikos, ein Teil davon ist natürlich wiederum,
dass wir zwei Experimente mit unterschiedlichen Technologien haben.
Und es gibt natürlich noch eine endliche Zahl von Detektor-Technologien,
aber das heißt gewisse Elemente werden ähnlich sein,
aber in den Details unterscheiden sie sich dann und vor allem in der Gesamtkonzeption
unterscheiden sich die zwei Experimente.
Gut, dann schauen wir doch mal darauf, was jetzt im Falle von CMS tatsächlich gebaut wurde.
Wie ist sozusagen das Design des Detektors?
Im Namen steckt ja schon so einiges drin. Also im Prinzip das Bauprinzip,
wenn ich das richtig sehe, ist hier unter anderem mit enkodiert.
Und wie muss man sich das vorstellen? Wie groß ist das Ding? Erzähl doch mal.
Also wie gesagt, wir haben ein Kompakt im Namen. Das könnte vielleicht etwas
täuschen, weil der Detektor wiegt über 10.000,
Tonnen, ist über 20 Meter lang und circa 15 Meter Durchmesser,
also ungefähr die Größe eines Hauses.
Und dieses Volumen ist zum großen Teil mit Präzisionstechnologie gefüllt.
Das Grundprinzip, das gilt auch für Atlas, ist,
dass wir idealerweise, wir haben diese Kollisionen,
die im Beschleuniger stattfinden, daraus entstehen Sekundärteilchen,
sehr viele, hunderte, tausende, und idealerweise wollen wir alle diese Teilchen
messen und ein Maximum der Eigenschaften jedes dieses Teilchens messen.
Leider gibt es kein Detektor-Konzept, das alle Eigenschaften gleichzeitig messen kann.
Mit Eigenschaften meine ich da zum Beispiel den Ursprungspunkt,
weil es gibt natürlich Teilchen, die direkt aus dem Punkt kommen,
an dem Protonen oder Atomkerne kollidiert sind.
Aber es gibt dann auch Zwischenstufen. Es gibt kurzlebige Teilchen,
die dort erzeugt werden, ein Stück weit fliegen, dann in weitere Teilchen zerfallen.
Das heißt, wir wollen wissen, ob Teilchen vom ursprünglichen Kollisionspunkt
kommen oder aus dem Zerfall eines kurzlebigen Teilchens kommen.
Wir wollen die Richtung wissen.
Wir wollen idealerweise die Art des Teilchens wissen, seine Masse und natürlich seine Energie.
Und um das für alle wichtigen Teilchenarten zu erzielen, gibt es nur die Möglichkeit,
dass man mehrere Detektorsysteme kombiniert, weil eben ein einzelnes System
nicht alle diese Eigenschaften messen kann.
Das heißt, ganz grob gesagt, teilt sich der Detektor in drei Zonen, je nach Teilchentyp.
Im innersten Teil des Detektors versuchen wir die Flugbahn von geladenen Teilchen festzustellen.
Also damit kann man eben auch den Produktionsort feststellen,
die Richtung und wir können auch den Impuls feststellen.
Das heißt im klassischen Fall ist Impuls einfach das Produkt aus Masse und Geschwindigkeit.
Im relativistischen Fall, unsere Teilchen, die dort erzeugt werden,
sind alle normalerweise relativ nah an der Lichtgeschwindigkeit.
Es ist etwas komplizierter, aber es gibt jedenfalls einen Zusammenhang zwischen
Energie, diesem Impuls und der Masse eines Teilchens.
Und das erzielen wir dadurch, dass wir eben ein starkes Magnetfeld im Großteil des Detektors haben.
Und dieses Magnetfeld wird die geladene Teilchen auf Helixbahnen zwingen.
Und aus der Krümmung dieser Helixbahnen kann man dann den Impuls berechnen.
Die Idee ist, dass man in diesem Volumen die Teilchen möglichst wenig und unter
Anführungszeichen stört.
Das heißt, wir wollen diesen Teil des Detektors möglichst leicht bauen,
damit die Teiche nicht mit Material kollidieren und sich in andere Teiche umwandeln.
Und das ist sozusagen die erste Zone. Die zweite Zone wird verwendet,
um die Energie der meisten Teilchen zu messen, indem man sie de facto absorbiert.
Das heißt, dort kehrt man das Prinzip sozusagen um.
Man hat eine Zone mit sehr dichtendem Material.
Und in dem dichten Material werden die einlaufenden Teilchen eine Wechselwirkung
mit Atomkernen oder Elektronen machen.
Das wird neue Teichen erzeugen und diese neuen Teichen können wiederum kollidieren
und wiederum neue Teichen erzeugen. Das heißt, das ist ein Lawineneffekt.
Das heißt, man hat eine Multiplikation der Teilchen, die dort in diesem Schauer
entstehen und das geht so lange, bis die Energie der Teilchen,
die durchschnittliche Energie der Teilchen so weit gesunken ist,
dass sie keine neuen Teilchen mehr erzeugen können.
Weil das ganze geschieht natürlich über die übliche Äquivalenz zwischen Energie und Masse.
Das heißt, solange die einlaufenden Teilchen Energien haben,
die über der Masse anderer Teilchen liegen, können sie neue Teilchen überzeugen.
Und das heißt, irgendwann einmal fällt die Energie und der Schauer wird beendet.
Und aus der Größe des Schauers, aus der Zahl der Teilchen mit dem Schauer,
können wir die Energie des einlaufenden Teilchens rückrechnen.
Habe ich das gerade richtig verstanden? Also die eigentliche Kollision,
klar die löst du jetzt erstmal aus, dann gibt es halt nachfolgende Prozesse,
wo dann eben weitere Zerfallsprodukte entstehen, weil das einfach die Eigenschaft
dieser Teilchen ist, dass sie nicht langlebig sind.
Aber das System ist schon so aufgebaut, dass man dann ab einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt
auch schon bewusst anderes Material bereit hält, einfach um dann noch weitere
sekundäre Kollisionen geschehen zu lassen.
Die sekundären Kollisionen in dieser zweiten Zone werden sozusagen absichtlich
herbeigeführt, eben um die Energie dieses einlaufenden Teilchens messen zu können.
Und diesen Bereich werden die allermeisten Teilchen nicht verlassen.
Also vielleicht sollte man dann hier sprechen, ein bisschen über die Teilchenarten,
die wir da messen können. Also wir haben im Wesentlichen...
Das Standardmodell mit eigentlich vier Wechselwirkungen, aber die Gravitation,
die Schwerkraft spielt hier bei den Experimenten de facto keine Rolle.
Das heißt wir haben die elektromagnetische Wechselwirkung, schwache Wechselwirkung,
starke Wechselwirkung und wie sich Teilchen innerhalb eines Detektors verhalten,
hängt davon ab, welchen dieser Wechselwirkungen sie unterliegen.
Um es gleich nochmal klar zu machen für alle, die nicht ganz so in der Materie
drinstecken, mit Wechselwirkung meinen wir jetzt im Prinzip die fundamentalen Kräfte der Natur.
Schwerkraft kennen wir alle, leiden wir täglich drüber, aber wir würden es noch
dürrer finden, wenn sie nicht da wäre.
Also die starke Kernkraft und man sagt halt hier eher Wechselwirkung,
weil das ist sozusagen das, was man in diesem Teilchensystem sieht oder was dort,
was wir meinen oder glauben, wissen, was dort stattfindet, eine Interaktion
zwischen diesen Teilchen und manche Teilchen sind halt mehr so dieses Ist und
manche sind mehr so das Wird und diese Wirtsteilchen, das ist sozusagen diese
Kräfte, von denen wir sprechen.
Starke Kernkraft ist halt das, was im Kern, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes,
die Kerne auch zusammenhält, also dafür sorgt, dass nicht alles auseinander fliegt.
Die schwache Kernkraft kennt man halt so ein bisschen auch unter dem Aspekt
der Radioaktivität, dass man sozusagen auch in der Lage ist,
Obwohl schwach in irgendeiner Form das Ganze auch immer mal wieder sich auflösen
zu lassen. Finde ich auch einen schönen Regulationsmechanismus.
Es bleibt halt nicht alles so wie es ist, sondern mit einer bestimmten Wahrscheinlichkeit
fliegt der ganze Kram dann einfach so aus sich heraus, mehr oder weniger, auseinander.
Und dann halt noch der gesamte Elektromagnetismus, den wir alle toll finden,
jeder hat schon mal in die Steckdose gefasst.
Und das hält ja auch irgendwie alles zusammen, das heißt gerade die schwache
und die starke Kernkraft,
würde ich sagen, das ist hier so der Hauptfokus, während die elektromagnetische
Kraft eigentlich eher so ein bisschen der nützliche Idiot ist,
um das genauer anzuschauen oder gibt's Tatsachen?
Nicht ganz, weil de facto war ja etwas, was man in den 80er Jahren eigentlich
bewiesen hat, ist, dass die elektromagnetische Kraft und die schwache Kraft
eigentlich nur zwei Seiten derselben Metalle sind.
Und dass wir sie nur so unterschiedlich sehen, weil wir hier normalerweise bei
sehr niedrigen Energien arbeiten, Aber wenn man sich Kollisionen bei sehr hoher Energie ansieht,
dann sieht man, dass das eigentlich dasselbe Phänomen ist, nur in zwei Arten.
Ja, und um auf den Detektor zurückzukommen. Es gibt eben Detektorteile,
die sind spezialisiert auf Teilchen, die hauptsächlich elektromagnetisch wechselwirken,
also geladene Teilchen oder Photonen, Lichtteilchen, die de facto diese elektromagnetische
Wechselwirkung vermitteln, diese elektromagnetischen Kräfte vermitteln.
Und dann gibt es Hadronen, das heißt Teilchen, die auch der starken Wechselwirkung unterliegen.
Und die manifestieren sich eben anders und die zum Beispiel im Detektor erzeugen,
diese Schauer werden länger sein und das heißt man hat einen speziellen Teil
des Detektors für diese Art Teilchen.
Hadronen muss man nochmal dazu sagen, das ist das, was den Atomkern im Wesentlichen
ausmacht, also was Protonen und Neutronen formt.
Protonen und Neutronen sind Hadronen, aber es gibt einen ganzen Zuf von Teilchen.
Nur so zur Einordnung. Hadronen ist der allgemeine Begriff für das,
was unter anderem Protonen und Neutronen formt.
Genau. Und dann nach dieser zweiten Zone bleibt eigentlich nicht mehr sehr viel übrig.
Dort sind eben die meisten Teilchen sozusagen stecken geblieben und es bleiben
eigentlich nur mehr Teilchen über,
die eben in der Lage sind, sehr große Dichten von Stärken von Material zu durchdringen
und das sind einerseits die Myonen.
Also die Myonen, das ist ein Schwester oder Bruder des Elektrons.
Das heißt im Wesentlichen haben sie alle Eigenschaften,
die auch Elektron hat, das sehr bekannte Elektron hat,
aber sie sind wesentlich schwerer und das führt dazu, dass sie eben wesentlich
leichter durch Material durchdringen können und der beste Beweis dafür Dafür
ist die Höhenstrahlung.
Das sind also Myonen, die bei Kollisionen, so wie diese Lawinenartigen Schauer,
die ich beschrieben habe, die entstehen natürlich nicht nur im Detektor,
sondern können auch in der Atmosphäre entstehen, wenn hochenergetische Teilchen
aus dem Weltraum eindringen.
Und die Myonen, die dabei entstehen, können bis zur Erdoberfläche laufen und
de facto sogar unter die Erdoberfläche, weil unsere Detektoren hier am LHC,
die so etwa 100 Meter unter der Erde liegen, sehen noch immer Myonen aus der Höhenstrahlung.
Und diese Myonen können eben die meisten Detektorschichten durchlaufen und die
werden dann in der letzten Zone, im äußersten Teil des Detektors gesehen.
Das ist sehr praktisch, weil dadurch können wir sie sehr leicht identifizieren.
Wie gesagt, wir würden auch gerne wissen, um welches Teilchen es sich in jedem Fall handelt.
Und die Teilchen, die wir in dieser äußersten Zone sehen, sind praktisch ausschließlich Myonen.
Und da steckt ja auch ein Name mit drin.
Genau. Die Myonen, die erlauben, wir können Myonen sehr präzise messen.
Sie sind also ein sehr wichtiges Instrument, um zu verstehen,
was in einer Kollision passiert.
Und gleichzeitig werden wir die Kollisionen, die hier im Beschleuniger entstehen,
laufen hauptsächlich über die starke Wechselwirkung.
Was in der Kollision passiert, ist im Wesentlichen eine Auswirkung der starken Wechselwirkung.
Und dabei werden sehr wenige Elektronen, Myonen oder ähnliche Teilchen erzeugt.
Das heißt, es ist auch einfach, diese Myonen zu detektieren,
weil neben den hunderten Teilchen, die da entstehen können bei jeder Kollision,
gibt es jeweils nur höchstens einige wenige Myonen geben.
Und deswegen ist die Detektion einfacher und deswegen ist das Experiment auch
sehr stark darauf ausgelegt worden, dass man Myonen messen kann,
die zum Beispiel auch wichtig sind, um das berühmte X-Person zu messen und zu finden.
Vielleicht mal so als Nebeneinschub, wenn man das jetzt mal mit so der Kernspaltung
im Atomkraftwerk vergleicht, wenn man jetzt hier Atomkerne aufeinander ballert
und die in ihre tausend Teilchen zerschießen, dann ist das ja im Prinzip auch eine Kernspaltung.
Nicht ganz. Also was man wirklich verstehen sollte ist, dass bei den Energien
mit denen wir hier arbeiten, diese Energien liegen viele Größenordnungen über
den Energien, die typischerweise in einem Atomkern auftreten.
Und bei diesen Energien, wenn zum Beispiel zwei Protonen aufeinandertreffen,
findet die Kollision nicht zwischen den Protonen als Protonobjekt 1 und Protonobjekt
2 statt, sondern die Kollision findet statt zwischen Bestandteilen der Protonen.
Also in den Protonen und Neutronen haben wir Quarks, was wir Up- und Down-Quarks nennen.
Das sind also etwas seltsame Teilchen, weil sie nicht frei in der Natur vorkommen.
Diese Bestandteile sind immer eingeschlossen in die berühmten Hadronen.
Also Hadronen enthalten immer… Also sie kommen in der Natur vor, aber nicht einzeln.
Genau, sie kommen nicht frei in der Natur vor.
Und die Hypothese dieser Quarks hat erlaubt eben eine Ordnung in diesem Zoo
zu bringen, man dadurch die Teilchen klassifizieren konnte, je nachdem welche Quarks sie enthalten.
Und de facto, wenn zwei Protonen hier im LHC zusammenstoßen,
ist die Kollision, die uns interessiert,
ist die Kollision entweder zwischen einem Quark aus dem einen Proton und einem
Quark aus dem anderen Proton oder aber,
was hier sehr oft passiert, das Proton ist ein komplexes Objekt.
Also im Prinzip, man lernt in der Schule.
Das Proton besteht aus drei Quarks, aber in Wirklichkeit ist mehr Leben in diesem Proton.
Und vor allem gibt es da Gluronan.
Das Gluronan ist das Äquivalent des Photons, des Lichtteilchens für die elektromagnetische
Wechselwirkung, da in diesem Fall für die starke Wechselwirkung.
Das heißt, das sind die Teilchen, die die starke Wechselwirkung übertragen zwischen
zwei Quarks zum Beispiel.
Und das Proton ist de facto voll von diesen Glurnan, die die Quarks de facto
im Proton zusammenhalten.
Und das heißt, wir können auch Kollisionen zwischen diesen Q-Unern haben,
wenn die zwei Protonen sich treffen.
Das heißt der Unterschied ist, weil ich mich gefragt habe,
wenn so viel kollidiert und man das vergleichen kann, so Kernkraftwechsel ist
halt sehr viel Radioaktivität frei, inwiefern ist dann diese Kollision anders?
Geschieht das dort auch oder ist das eben weil die Energie so hoch ist,
dass alles so dermaßen zertrümmert wird, dass sich das komplett anders verhält?
Ja, wie gesagt, die Energien sind so hoch, dass de facto ein zerfallenes Atomkern,
ein zerfallenes und komplexes Objekt, das aus vielen Protonen und Neutronen
besteht, und der wird sich de facto in zwei Teile spalten, weil energetisch
der Ausgangszustand günstiger ist.
Aber das spielt sich typischerweise bei Energien. Die Energien,
die in diese Prozesse involviert sind, sind typischerweise in der Million-Elektron-Volt-Gegend.
Um das zu vergleichen, ist die circa tausendmal höher als typische Röntgenstrahlung,
wenn man einen Vergleich haben will.
Und wir reden hier über Giga-Elektron-Volt, also Milliarde-Elektron-Volt oder
noch einen Faktor tausend drüber.
Das heißt, wie gesagt, bei diesen Prozessen, das ist keine Spaltung,
weil wir hier wirklich mit Elementarteilchen arbeiten.
Das ist eine Zerschmetterung.
Es ist eine Umwandlung. Es ist eine Umwandlung, weil Zerschmetterung würde voraussetzen,
dass das Teilchen aus Bestandteilen besteht.
Während das wir hier mit, was uns interessiert, sind die Elementarteilchen.
Das heißt Teilchen, von denen wir keine innere Struktur kennen,
von denen wir glauben, dass sie wirklich elementar sind.
Die niedrigsten Elemente, Bestandteile der Materie darstellen.
Das heißt, man kann es zerschmettern, ist das vielleicht ein schlechter Ausdruck,
weil sie keine Bestandteile haben. Und was passiert, ist eine Umwandlung.
Ja ich meinte nicht die Teilchen werden zerschmettert, da habe ich mich vielleicht falsch ausgerückt,
sondern die Struktur wird zerschmettert, also in dem Moment wo diese Bindung von den Quarks,
Glonen und so weiter alles komplett aufgelöst wird in seine wirklichen elementaren
Teilchen, dann ist sozusagen die komplette Struktur dessen was kollidiert ist
sozusagen vollständig aufgelöst.
Ja, es stimmt natürlich, das was zerschmettert wird, ist das Proton, d.h.
Zwei Bestandteile, ein Bestandteil aus jedem Proton kollidiert und macht eine
Wechselwirkung, erzeugt neue Teilchen, das ist der Prozess, der uns interessiert.
Aber das Proton, wenn das passiert, wird das Proton de facto zerstört,
weil das Proton aus drei Quarks besteht und wenn man da Bestandteile herausschlägt,
gibt es kein Proton mehr, d.h.
Der Rest des Protons wird sich auch in neue Teilchen umwandeln.
Das ist aber ein für uns eher ein störender Untergrund als das was uns wirklich interessieren.
Ja der Rest des Protons wird sich auch in neue Teilchen.
Aber Radioaktivität in dem Sinne wird da nicht frei?
Nein, Radioaktivität ist ja der spontane Zerfall eines Atomkerns de facto.
Und während wir hier eine induzierte Kollision zwischen zwei Teilchen,
die also größtenteils unter der Größe eines Atomkerns liegen.
Ja man muss ja auch über gefühlte Gefahren reden.
Wir hatten ja schon in der Ausgangsdiskussion die Diskussion um schwarze Löcher,
die hier erzeugt werden, da ist ja ein Weltuntergang drohen.
De facto ist natürlich die Teilchen, die aus der Kollision hinauslaufen,
sind natürlich Strahlung.
Das heißt das könnte ionisierende Strahlung und deswegen ist auch die Detektorzone
während wir operieren abgeschlossen.
Bevor wir vielleicht gleich mal so den eigentlichen Messvorgang selber aus der
Perspektive eines Teilchens dann oder eines Protons erstmal beobachten,
würde ich ganz gerne nochmal von außen nach innen gehen.
Also haben wir ja schon gesagt, es ist ein relativ großes System.
Was war das? 15 Meter ungefähr?
Super schwer, sehr viel Material und vor allem ist es halt ein,
ich meine was der Name ja auch sagt, Solenoid, also sozusagen eine riesige Spule,
eine Magnetspule, wie man das halt so aufgebückt kennt.
Eine ganz kerstliche Spule, ja. Quasi wie so ein riesiges dynamisches Mikrofon.
Und dieser Apparat sitzt wo genau? Wie tief?
Der Apparat sitzt auf dem Niveau des Beschleunigers natürlicherweise und das
heißt das ist knappe 100 Meter tief.
In einer Kaverne in der von beiden Seiten der Beschleuniger Tunnel einmündet.
Ist es da eigentlich warm?
Normale Temperatur, Umgebungstemperatur.
Wenn man sich so dem Erdkern nähert, wird es ja irgendwann warm.
Bleibt doch etwas Abstand. Also Frost gibt es auf jeden Fall keinen.
Nein, Frost gibt es keiner.
Die Größe des Apparats hängt de facto mit der Energie der Kollisionen und daraus
folgender Energie der Teilchen, die aus der Kollision erzeugt werden, zusammen.
Ich habe von diesen Schauern gesprochen. Diese Schauer wachsen mit der Energie
des Teilchens, werden diese Schauer immer größer.
Und um eine präzise Messung der Energie zu erhalten, möchten wir,
dass der gesamte Schauer im Detektor enthalten ist und nicht,
dass gewisse Teilchen sich hinten aus dem Detektor rauslaufen würden.
Und nachdem eben diese Schauer mit der Energie wachsen und wir die Dichte des
Materials nicht beliebig erhöhen können,
weil wir müssen mit Materialien arbeiten, die es gibt, kann man diese Detektoren
mit höherer Energie einfach nur dicker machen. Das ist der eine Grund.
Der andere Grund, ich habe von der Impulsmessung und geladenen Teilchen gesprochen.
Also der Sinn der großen Spule ist, dass geladene Teilchen eben auf eine Helix
oder in einer Projektion, Kreisbahn abgelenkt werden.
Dadurch können wir die Ladung messen, weil die positive und negative Teilchen
werden sich in unterschiedliche Richtungen wegrümmen und aus der Stärke der
Krümmung können wir eben diesen Impuls abmessen.
Und bei den Energien, die wir produzieren, ist diese Krümmung aber sehr gering.
Und das heißt, um diese Krümmung messen zu können, gibt es zwei Möglichkeiten.
Man erhöht die Präzision des Detektors, weil wir messen eben die Bahn an verschiedenen
Orten und wenn man dann verschiedene Punkte misst, kann man irgendwann einmal
sehen, dass diese Punkte nicht auf einer geraden Linie liegen,
sondern eben eine leichte Probe machen.
Aber wie gut man das messen kann, hängt natürlich von der Präzision ab,
mit der man jeden Punkt messen kann.
Und diese Präzision hat natürlich auch ein Limit, ihre Grenzen.
Und die zweite Möglichkeit ist, dass man die Krümmung vergrößert bei gleicher
Energie und das heißt ein größeres Magnetfeld, das heißt eine sehr starke Spule.
Und in CMS de facto haben wir versucht beides zu machen.
Ein sehr sehr starkes Magnetfeld, also 3,8 Tesla, das ist größenordnungsmäßig
100.000 mal das Erdmagnetfeld und gleichzeitig sehr Präzisedetektoren im Innenraum der Spur.
Wenn man da runter geht, dann muss man sich auch all seine metallischen Dinge empfehlen.
Ja, wenn die Spule eingeschaltet ist. Es ist zwar, was man außen sieht, ist nur ein Rest Feld.
Wenn man so eine Spule einfach frei in den Raum stellen würde,
dann würde man ein Magnetfeld im großen Umkreis um den Detektor erzeugen.
Das möchten wir natürlich nicht.
Das heißt, die Spule ist komplementiert, und das macht den Großteil der Struktur
des Detektors aus, durch einen Rückflussjoch.
Also, um es einfach zu sagen, die Spule an der Detektor ist eingebettet in ein
Stahlkorsett, de facto, und dieses schließt die magnetischen Feldlinien.
Das heißt, die magnetischen Feldlinien laufen durch die Spule und dann durch
den Stahl wieder zurück Und das bewirkt,
dass außen zwar nicht null, weil das System nicht perfekt ist,
aber ein sehr viel geringeres Magnetfeld herrscht.
Dieses sehr viel geringere Magnetfeld ist allerdings immer noch stark genug,
um einfach sichtbar zu sein und in Führungen.
Aber es reißt einem jetzt nicht die Armbanduhr vom Arm?
Es reißt nicht die Armbandufe am Arm, aber wenn man nahe an den Detektor geht,
sollte man keine magnetischen Werkzeuge oder ähnliches haben.
Man kennt ja diese Problematik aus der Medizin mit so einem Magnetresonanzsystem und so weiter.
Da ist es ja ein echtes Problem, wenn man da mal was mit reinbringt.
Genau, wir bewegen uns in denselben Größenordnungen und das heißt natürlich
auch, dass alle Komponenten im Detektor nicht magnetisch sein sollten.
Aber wie gesagt außen in Führungen verwenden wir oft eine kleine Kette von Büroklammern
und man sieht klar auch außerhalb vom Detektor und in einem Abstand vom Detektor,
dass diese Kette nicht gerade hinunter hängt.
Wäre das, würde man sich jetzt in der Mitte befinden, wenn der Magnet eingeschaltet ist?
Nur so als Mensch nackt, würde einem das schaden? Also ist das ein Problem für
den menschlichen Körper oder ist es egal?
Im Prinzip sollte das egal sein, weil wir uns in den selben Größenordnungen
bewegen wie für medizinische Untersuchungen, Magnetesresonanz.
Na gut, also auf jeden Fall eine fette Spule.
Sie würden aber wahrscheinlich Effekte sehen, wenn sie sich bewegen,
wenn sich jemand bewegt im Detektor.
Im magnetischen Feld, das löst ja Ströme aus.
Also man würde es stören, aber man würde nicht sterben. Ja.
Okay, also so ein riesen Magnetspuler, die dann aber auch noch gekühlt werden
muss, nehme ich an, also ordentlich?
Genau, das ist meines Wissens immer der größte supraleitende Magnet, der existiert.
Das heißt, um dieses starke Magnetfeld zu erzeugen, verwenden wir einen Niob-Titan-Leiter,
der supraleitend wird, wenn man ihn auf etwa 4 Grad über dem absoluten Nullpunkt kühlt.
Und diese Kühlung passiert mit flüssigem Helium. Und das macht natürlich die
Komplexität des Systems aus.
Man muss flüssiges Helium erzeugen, man muss die Spule natürlich thermisch isolieren,
Das heißt, die ist in einem Vakuumtank eingebettet, sozusagen eine riesige Thermosflasche.
Und man muss garantieren können, dass die Spule immer kalt bleibt,
weil man muss sich vorstellen, der Leiter,
also der elektrische Leiter, der dort ausgewickelt ist in der Spule,
der hat eine Breite von einigen Zentimetern und eine Dicke von einigen Millimetern
Und durch diesen Leiter laufen 18.000 Ampere.
Das wäre für normal leitende...
Das heißt, man muss sicherstellen, dass die Spule im super leitenden Zustand bleibt.
Und falls man glaubt, dass die Kühlung nicht mehr aufrechterhalten werden kann
oder so, muss man die Spule möglichst schnell und kontrolliert abschalten.
Weil man muss verstehen, dass im Magnetfeld kann man de facto Energie speichern.
Das heißt, wenn das Magnetfeld aufgebaut wird, wird de facto Energie dort hineingebombt
und im Magnetfeld gespeichert.
In unserem Fall sind das ca. 2 Gigajoule.
Das ist eine nicht vernachlässigbare Menge, mit der man eine Menge Metall zum
Beispiel schmelzen könnte.
Und sollte man die Kühlung nicht aufrechterhalten können, muss man dafür sorgen,
dass man diese große Energie aus den Magneten möglichst schnell extrahiert,
damit es keine Beschädigungen im Magnet ergibt. Das ist eine der technischen...
So ein Abschalten-Moment?
Ja, wir versuchen das möglichst selten zu haben, aber es ist schon zweimal vorgekommen,
dass wir ihn schnell abschalten wollen.
Aber hat dann zumindest auch funktioniert und das glimpfliche auch.
Hat alles funktioniert, ja.
Wenn ich das richtig sehe, ist ja CMS nicht vor Ort gebaut worden,
sondern erstmal woanders und dann da rein.
Also CMS, diese Detektoren werden von Kollaborationen gebaut,
die aus vielen Instituten bestehen. In CMS haben wir inzwischen mehr als 200
Universitäts- oder andere wissenschaftliche Institute, die da mitarbeiten.
Und normalerweise, wenn man diesen Konten aus so einem Detektor baut,
trägt jedes Institut einen gewissen Teil bei.
Und die Konstruktion basiert von kleinen Elementen zu immer größeren Elementen.
Also viele der grundlegenden Bestandteile werden in Industrie gefertigt und
sie werden dann sukzessive am Anfang in den Instituten zusammengebaut zu immer größeren Elementen.
Und der finale Zusammenbau geschieht dann normalerweise hier am CERN.
Und für CMS war das eine spezielle Komplikation, weil als wir anfangen mussten,
den Detektor zusammenzubauen, also die Konstruktion der Elemente hat ungefähr
im Jahr 2000 begonnen, war die Kaverne im Untergrund noch nicht fertiggestellt.
Und wir konnten aus Zeitgründen nicht warten auf die Fertigstellung,
um das normale Prozedere zu machen, das heißt den Detektor in kleinen Stücken
unten direkt vor Ort in der Kaverne aufzubauen.
Also man hätte das eigentlich gerne getan, aber das macht man auch nicht.
Das wäre eine normale Vorgangsweise gewesen. Aber es ging nicht und deswegen,
was wir gemacht haben, wir hatten über der Detektorzone eine große Halle und
wir haben angefangen den Detektor dort aufzubauen.
Und er ist de facto vollständig in dieser Halle aufgebaut worden und der Aufbau
wurde aber so gemacht, dass er in größere Stücke zerlegt werden konnte.
Also insgesamt 15 Stücke, davon 11 wirklich sehr große.
Man muss sich vorstellen, dass das größte Stück, das auch den Magneten enthalten
hat, ca. 2000 Tonnen wiegt.
Und als die Kaverne fertig war, wir haben einen sehr großen Zugangsschacht,
der so diese 80, 90 Meter hinunter geht, bis er die Kaverne erreicht.
Und es wurde dann ein riesiger Kran gemietet, der 2000 Tonnen tragen kann.
Die kleine Komplexität dabei ist, dass diese Kräne nicht mehr beweglich sind.
Das heißt, dieser Kran wurde direkt über dem Schacht aufgebaut.
Und der Schacht kann durch einen Deckel verschlossen werden,
der mehr als einen Meter Stahlbeton besteht.
Und das System war dann, dass wir jeweils eines von diesen Detektorstücken auf
den Deckel verschoben haben.
Der Kran hat ihn dann dort aufgehoben, man hat den Deckel geöffnet und ihn dann
in einer Operation, die halben Tag typischerweise gebraucht hat,
das Teil runtergelassen bis in die Kaverne.
Dann in der Kaverne verschoben, damit wieder Platz wird und das nächste Teil runtergelassen.
Das war eine Operation, die von circa 2006 bis 2008 gedauert hat insgesamt.
Krass. Dieses Konzept hat aber den Vorteil gehabt, oder hat noch immer den Vorteil,
dass wir dieses Verschieben von Teilen auch jetzt für die Wartung des Detektors verwenden können.
Der Beschleuniger läuft typischerweise den Großteil des Jahres und wir haben
dann eine Pause von zwei Monaten oder in der Größenordnung in der Winterperiode.
Das wird für Wartungen benutzt oder Verbesserungen. Und dieses System mit den
verschiedenen großen Teilen kann benutzt werden, um die Teile unten in der Kaverne
zu verschieben und dadurch Zugang zu den Zonen zwischen den Teilen zu bekommen.
Okay. Aus der Not eine Tugend gemacht sozusagen.
Mhm.
Gut, dann würde ich sagen, schauen wir doch mal, wie das jetzt wirklich in Operation aussieht.
Also wir haben ja auch schon über den Beschleunigerring gesprochen. Die Teilchen,
die man halt haben will, werden so einer Quelle entnommen und werden dann auf
die Reise geschickt und landen dann eben über die einzelnen Kaskaden von Ringen im LHC,
in dem großen 27 Kilometer Ring und erhalten dort ihre finale Geschwindigkeit
und entlang dieses LHC sind die vier großen Detektoren aufgebaut.
Über LS haben wir schon gesprochen, jetzt halt CMS. Wo befindet sich CMS,
schon in der Schweiz oder in Frankreich?
CMS befindet sich in Frankreich, also der einzige Detektor der in der Schweiz steht ist Atlas.
Und wir befinden uns genau auf der entgegengesetzten Seite des Rings im Vergleich
zum Hauptgelände des CERN.
Also maximal weiter Weg.
Maximal weiter Weg, was natürlich die Operation des Detektors und den Betrieb
des Detektors nicht erleichtert.
Wir haben natürlich einen Kontrollraum beim Detektor, der ständig besetzt ist
und das heißt, die Leute müssen vom CERN typischerweise dorthin fahren.
Ihr seid so ein bisschen die da draußen sozusagen.
Ja, okay, gut.
So jetzt kommen also die Teilchen dort an und werden dann ja auf den letzten
Metern auch nochmal aus dieser Kreisbahn quasi herausgenommen und fliegen dann
gerade in diesen Detektor rein.
So und jetzt bin ich ein Proton, was da sozusagen angeschossen kommt.
Mir kommt ein anderes, entsprechend anders herum geladenes Teilchen entgegen.
Und durch ein Wunder treffe ich jetzt genau auf dieses Teilchen.
Also nicht jedes Teilchen, was da durchfliegt, trifft auch auf eins,
nehme ich mal an, viele fliegen aneinander vorbei.
Nachdem die starke Wechselwirkung eben stark ist, passiert praktisch bei jeder
Kreuzung etwas. Man muss natürlich dazu sagen, dass die Protonen nicht einzeln
im Beschleuniger fliegen, sondern sie kommen in Paketen.
Wir haben im Beschleuniger einige tausend Pakete von Protonen,
die knapp beisammen sind und dann größenordnungsmäßig
acht Meter wieder Pause oder in
Zeit ausgedrückt 25 Milliarden Sekunden und
dann kommt das nächste Protonpaket und um sich eine Vorstellung zu machen in
jedem dieser Pakete sind circa 100 Milliarden Protonen und das heißt diese beiden
de facto kreuzen sich diese beiden Pakete und es können sich da bei jeder Kreuzung,
können ein oder mehrere Protonkollisionen stattfinden und um die Intensität,
wir wollen natürlich möglichst viele Protonkollisionen sehen,
weil um unsere Physikzielsetzungen zu erreichen,
möchten wir einerseits möglichst hohe Energien erreichen, um möglicherweise
neue schwere Teilchen zu erzeugen und wir möchten möglichst hohe Intensität,
möglichst viele Protonkollisionen haben, weil wir Prozesse sehen wollen, die extrem selten sind.
Aber zwei Pakete treffen quasi
aufeinander. Jedes enthält 100 Milliarden Protonen, also Pi mal Daumen.
Und wenn diese zwei Pakete von je 100 Milliarden Protonen aufeinander treffen,
dann gibt es ein oder ein Paar Kollisionen?
Also die ursprüngliche Auslegung des LHC war typischerweise 25 gleichzeitige
Kollisionen zu haben. Jedes Mal, wenn es...
Alle 25 Nanosekunden.
Ja, das ist nur zufällig dieselbe Zahl und inzwischen ist es dem Beschleuniger
gelungen die Intensität zu erhöhen.
Durch eine höhere Verdichtung dieses Pakets.
Genau und letztes Jahr hatten wir typischerweise über 50 und dieses Jahr werden wir noch mehr haben.
Aber die finden ja dann alle gleichzeitig statt, das heißt man beobachtet sie
auch alle gleichzeitig.
Ist das nicht eher ein Problem, wenn man zu viele gleichzeitig hat,
weil dann muss man sie ja auch auseinander halten.
Das ist potenziell ein Problem natürlich und die Detektoren wurden darauf auch ausgelegt.
Man muss jetzt natürlich sagen, sie wurden auf die berühmten ca.
25 ausgelegt und wir sind jetzt von mehr als einem Faktor 2 darüber.
Aber ja, sie finden gleichzeitig statt, aber die Zone, in der diese Kollisionen
stattfinden, erstreckt sich über plus minus 15 Zentimeter typischerweise.
Das heißt, diese Kollisionen finden nicht alle genau am selben Platz statt,
sondern sie sind etwas verteilt. Und wir können diesen Abstand verwenden,
um sie von einander zu unterscheiden.
Der zweite wichtige Aspekt ist, dass wir, wir suchen eben extrem seltene Prozesse,
in denen sehr viel Energie freigesetzt wird. Und das passiert bei Weitem nicht bei jeder Kollision.
Das heißt, aus den meisten Kollisionen werden wahrscheinlich nur wenige relativ
niederenergetische Teilchen entstehen.
Und eine, typisch maximal eine von diesen Kollisionen, wird ein Ereignis auslösen,
das uns interessiert und das wir messen wollen.
Dazu sollte man vielleicht auch sagen, dass eine der Herausforderungen ist,
dass der Detektor braucht, was wir ein Triggersystem nennen.
Das heißt wir brauchen ein System, das genau diese interessanten Kollisionen aussucht.
Weil die Gesamtzahl der Kollisionen,
man muss sich vorstellen, dass circa 30 Millionen mal pro Sekunde kreuzen sich
Pakete und der Detektor ist in der Lage diese 30 Millionen Fotos,
also er ist ausgelegt auf bis zu 40 Millionen Fotos pro Sekunde.
Aber das ist eine Datenmenge, die schwer zu handhaben wäre und in vielen dieser
Kollisionen passiert eben nichts, was uns interessieren würde.
Und deswegen brauchen wir ein System, das aus diesen 30 Millionen eine sieben wenige rausfiltert.
Und das ist eine ziemliche Herausforderung und das CMS hat sich früher entschieden
und das war technologisch zum Zeitpunkt der Auslegung des Experiments noch ein
bisschen auch eine Vorhersage oder eine Wette auf die zukünftige Entwicklung
von elektronischen Komponenten und Rechenleistung,
dass wir diese Auswahl in einem zweistufigen System machen.
Wir haben eine erste Stufe, das ist Elektronik, die sich unten nahe beim Detektor befindet.
Und diese Elektronik wird für jede Kollision ein paar Grunddaten bekommen über
Energie, die man im Detektor gesehen hat, die Anzahl zum Beispiel der Myonen
oder von Elektronen, die gesehen wurden.
Und aus diesen Daten kann sie sagen, ob wir dieses Foto behalten wollen oder nicht.
Und das muss geschehen in einigen Mikrosekunden.
Also die Elektronik hat einige Millionstel Sekunden Zeit, um für jedes Foto
zu sagen, wollen wir es behalten oder nicht.
Und nur wenn wir es behalten wollen, werden überhaupt alle Daten aus dem Detektor heraus transferiert.
Und wir können bis zu 100.000 pro Sekunde transferieren.
Das heißt, aus den ursprünglichen 30 Millionen pro Sekunde behalten wir mal
in dieser ersten Stufe 100.000 pro Sekunde.
Und in einem zweiten Schritt werden dann diese Daten, die aus dem Detektor gelesen
werden, werden an ein Computerzentrum transferiert, das wir auch vor Ort am Experiment haben.
Und dort können wir schon sozusagen eine beschleunigte Version der Auswerteprogramme
oder der ersten Stufe der Auswerteprogramme laufen lassen, die wir später dann verwenden auch.
Damit kann man natürlich sehr viel detaillierter nachsehen in allen Detektoren,
was passiert ist und eine viel detailliertere Analyse machen und deswegen auch genauer auswählen.
Und damit reduzieren wir dann die Rate von 100.000 auf einige Tausend pro Sekunde.
Das heißt von den 30 Millionen oder in der Größenordnung die Kreuzungen von
Paketen die im Detektor oder Fotos die im Detektor genommen werden,
behalten wir letztlich nur einige Tausend pro Sekunde. Junge Prosekunde.
Diese einigen tausend pro Sekunde, die werden dann permanent gespeichert und
das ist das, was für die Analyse nachher zur Verfügung steht.
Das muss man ja auch erstmal in so ein Computersystem gespeichert bekommen.
Das ist eine enorme Anforderung an die Geschwindigkeit, die da gestellt werden.
Diese erste Filterung ist hier gar nicht so sehr eine qualitative Filterung,
sondern mehr so ein Ranking und man nimmt dann sozusagen die hunderttausend,
die man übertragen kann, Nimmt man dann alle, um dann in der zweiten Stufe erst
auszusuchen, was für einen wertvoll ist oder ist es schon eine qualitative Auslesung?
Nein, nein. Das sind quantitative Kriterien und man kann, obwohl es nicht normale
CPUs sind, sondern Elektronikkomponenten.
Also quantitativ im Sinne von wie viele Spuren?
Wir können zum Beispiel verlangen, dass wir zwei Myonen übersehen,
die über einer gewissen Energie liegen.
Okay, also auch schon mit einer, ich meine jetzt qualitativ im Sinne von was sehen wir?
Also das wird auch schon berücksichtigt in dieser ersten Frage.
Genau, welche Arten von Teilchen haben wir gesehen, in welcher Zahl, bei welcher Energie.
Wir könnten auch auswählen, dass diese zwei Teilchen in gegengesetzte Richtungen geflogen sind.
Und da können wir einige hundert Kriterien definieren, die all diese Größen kombinieren.
Und wenn mindestens eines dieser Kriterien erfüllt ist, dann würden wir dieses Event auswählen.
Wenn es so schnell laufen soll, dann ist das schon so optimierte Hardware,
wo die Software dann voll in die Hardware eingebrannt ist und das voll beschleunigt?
Das sind FPGAs, das heißt das ist Elektronik, die programmierbar ist,
aber nicht programmierbar wie in dem.
Also damit das wirklich sehr schnell abläuft, weil das wäre jetzt für eine normale CPU zu schnell.
Alright, ja okay gut. Das ist also der Vorgang. Jetzt stellt sich natürlich
die Frage, wie funktioniert der Detektor eigentlich genau.
Klar kann man ja sagen, das haben wir ja in Muon gesehen, das muss man ja auch
erstmal sehen. Und wir hatten das im Prinzip, wir haben das auch schon,
als wir über Alice gesprochen haben, im Prinzip folgt das ja dem ähnlichen Modell.
Es geht einfach darum, durch diese magnetische Ablenkung, die durch diesen großen
Spulenmagneten hergestellt wird,
also sozusagen die ganzen Teilchen quasi in ihrer Ausbreitung,
in ihrer Abstrahlung irgendwie versucht, wieder in den Griff zu kriegen und
eben dieses starke Magnetfeld braucht, weil eben die Energien so hoch sind, die dort stattfinden.
Die wollen halt einfach irgendwo hinschießen und der Magnet sagt so, so nicht.
Ja, ich krümm dich jetzt mal hier so ein bisschen weg.
Und durch diese Krümmung, die man beobachtet,
dann ist es ja quasi so das Rennen zwischen Energie des Teilchens und deren
Richtung kämpft gegen das Magnetfeld Und daraus ergibt sich halt so eine Spurenkurve,
der man dann eben quasi nachsehen kann.
Okay, alles klar, wenn du so schnell unterwegs bist, weil die Zeit kann ich
ja messen, und dann diese Kurve machst, dann musst du sonst so schwer sein,
also bist du wahrscheinlich das und das Teilchen.
Und wie misst jetzt CMS diese...
Funktioniert das genauso wie bei ALICE oder kommt hier eine ganz andere Technologie zu?
Nein, wir verwenden andere Technologien. Wir verwenden eine Technologie,
die ALICE auch in den ganz innersten Tonen verwendet.
Das sind Siliziumdetektoren, das sind Pal-Beta-Detektoren.
Man muss sich vorstellen, das sind ganz dünne Scheiben von Silizium,
das speziell präpariert wird.
Im Wesentlichen ist die Idee dieselbe wie die Sensoren in einer Kamera.
Das heißt, das Silizium kann Lichtteilchen im Fall der Kamera oder geladene
Teilchen wie Myonen oder andere Teilchen in unserem Fall registrieren,
wenn diese Teilchen durch das Silizium durchlaufen.
Also quasi so CCDs, Charge Coupled Devices, sind das ja in der Kamera, als Ladung.
Aber in unserem Fall sind es keine CCDs, weil die CCDs viel zu langsam werden.
Weil eines der Grundprinzipien des Detektors ist natürlich, wie gesagt,
wir haben einen 25 Milliardstel Sekunden Abstand zwischen zwei Kollisionen.
Und das heißt, alle Detektoren müssen schnell genug ein Signal liefern,
um zwei Kollisionen unterscheiden zu können. Und das ginge bei CCDs nicht.
Und das heißt, de facto, was wir haben, ist Silizium. Und auf dem Silizium sind
Strukturen, Elektrodenstrukturen aufgebracht.
Und das sind entweder Streifen oder kleine Rechtecke.
Und jeder dieser Streifen und
jedes dieser Rechtecke hat seine eigene Verstärkung und Datenübertragung.
Das heißt, wir haben im Moment knappe 100 Millionen de facto aktive Elemente, so Streifen oder...
Und jedes dieser Elemente wird gleichzeitig ausgelesen. Das ist eben der Unterschied zur Kamera.
Und das ermöglicht einerseits eine sehr hohe Präzision.
Das heißt, die Präzision der innersten Lagen ist besser als 10 Millionsilometer.
Das heißt, das ist kleiner, dünner als ein Haar.
Hinaus nimmt es dann etwas zu, aber es ist immer noch in dieser Größenordnung. 10, 20, 30 Mikrometer.
Das heißt, wir haben eine Serie.
Diese Detektoren sind in Schichten angeordnet. Das heißt, im Zentraldetektor
sind das Zylinder. Das heißt, es ist jeweils eine zylindrische Schicht,
und die ist mit Detektoren, mit diesen dünnen Platten, vollgepflastert.
Und eine Schicht kommt nach der anderen.
Wie viele Schichten sind es dann?
Wir haben insgesamt im Moment, also im Zentralteil würde ein Teilchen 14 Schichten
durchlaufen und das heißt jede Schicht würde eine sehr sehr präzise Messung des Ortes.
Und der Abstand zwischen den Schichten ist konstant?
Nein, der Abstand vergrößert sich nach außen.
Was ist der kleinste und was ist der größte Abstand?
Der kleinste Abstand ist also Zentimeterbereich, 2 Zentimeter und nach außen
wird es größer, 10 Zentimeter Größenordnung.
Also der ganze Detektor, um sich das vorzustellen, geht bis zu einem Radius
von knapp über einem Meter.
Also knapp einen Meter von der Wechselwirkungszone, von der Kollisionszone entfernt.
Und mit diesen 14 Punkten, die kann man dann sozusagen verbinden und aus der
Verbindung dieser 14 Punkte sieht man dann diese berühmte Spur.
Genau, wo man dann Ort und Zeit hat, überall wo das Zeichen steht.
In unserem existierenden Detektor messen wir die Zeit nicht explizit.
Der Detektor ist so ausgelegt, dass er optimiert ist, jeweils für eine bestimmte
Kollision die Teilchen zu sehen. Aber wir messen die Zeit nicht explizit.
Wir werden das in der nächsten Generation von CMS machen, aber im derzeitigen
Detektor ist das nicht notwendig.
Was man da vielleicht auch erwähnen könnte, ist, dass man diese Punkte zu einer
Linie, also zu einem Kreis, wenn man so will, verbinden muss.
Die Komplexität ist natürlich, dass wir eben hunderte oder in Kollisionen von
Kernen tausende Teilchen haben,
die da fliegen und jedes dieser Teilchen hinterlässt natürlich Punkte in dem
Detektor und die ja je nachdem welcher Punkt oder Streifen getroffen wurde Und es ist natürlich,
diese Punkte haben kein Etikett, das sagen würde, ich bin von diesem Teich hingekommen.
Deswegen dachte ich ja, dass die Zeit ein wichtiger Faktor ist.
Nein, weil die Zeiten, die Teilchen laufen ja fast bei derselben Zeit,
weil sie wurden zur selben Zeit produziert und fliegen dann de facto mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit hinaus.
Und das heißt man hat ein Problem jeweils Punkte einem Teilchen zuzuordnen und
das ist ein ziemlich großer Rechenaufwand.
Also wenn man ein Foto sehen würde, an dem einfach die Punkte aufgetragen sind,
würde man mit freiem Auge nichts erkennen.
Das heißt es gibt Algorithmen, die dann eben die Punkte verbinden und das klassifizieren
in Teilchen und dann für jedes Teilchen aus der Krömung eben den Impuls,
die Energie ausrechnen.
Kann man dabei Fehler machen?
Natürlich. Es gibt natürlich Fehler, aber die Algorithmen sind eben so entwickelt
worden, um diese Fehler sehr gering zu halten, so gering zu halten,
dass sie de facto die letztlichen Messungen nicht beeinflussen.
Also Teilchen trifft auf, Kollision findet statt,
all das was dort aufeinander trifft wird dann eben in seine elementaren Teilchen
zerschmettert und die machen sich dann auf die Reise,
fliegen los und entweder streifen sie halt selber unmittelbar dann eine dieser
Schichten Oder auf dem Weg zerteilt sich eben dieses Teilchen nochmal in andere,
also von wegen Elementarteilchen, wenn es sich dann doch noch in andere Teilchen
verwandelt, kann es ja so elementar auch wieder nicht sein.
Egal, auf jeden Fall das findet statt und man hat es also bei jeder Kollision
mit einer Vielzahl von Durchschlagungspunkten zu tun,
also zumindest in diesem inneren 14 Schichten Bereich,
die man dann eben per Software wieder zueinander zuordnen und sagt okay,
wenn das da war, das da war, dann gehört das wahrscheinlich zusammen und dann
ist das die daraus resultierende Bahn und aus dieser Bahn kann ich dann wiederum errechnen,
okay was war das jetzt mit welcher Energie und damit weiß ich auch die Masse
und wenn man die Masse weiß, dann weiß man um was für ein Teilchen es sich gehandelt hat.
Und wie gesagt, worüber diese Siliziumdetektoren, das ist dieser erste Teil
des Detektors, von dem ich vorhin gesprochen habe, das heißt dieser Teil des
Detektors, der möglichst leicht gebaut werden soll.
Aber diese Phase reicht auch schon für die Klassifikation der Teilchen aus? Nein, noch nicht.
Nein, weil wir eben...
Die Information aus mehreren Detektoren kombinieren wollen.
Das heißt, wir haben so ein Teilchen, ein geladenes Teilchen,
das läuft durch den Detektor durch, wir messen die Punkte, wir verfolgen seine
Spur und dann wird es in den nächsten Detektor übergehen, eben in dieses Kalorimeter,
wo sehr viel Material ist, in dem das Teilchen de facto seine ganze Energie abgeben kann.
Das ist dann eine ganz andere Technologie.
Im Fall von CMS verwenden wir dabei Kristalle.
Das ist Blei-Wolframat.
Das sind sehr, sehr transparente Kristalle, die aber de facto die Dichte von Blei haben.
Das heißt, eine sehr große Dichte. Man stellt sehr viel Material entgegen,
um eben diese Schauer, diese Lawinen möglichst kurz zu halten.
Und Teilchen, besonders Elektronen oder Photonen, die dort in diese Kristalle
hineinlaufen, die werden den Kristall anregen und es wird Licht ausgesendet,
Stintillationslicht ausgesendet.
Das Licht wird im Kristall, der sehr transparent ist, weiterlaufen und jeder
von diesen circa 80.000 Kristallen hat dann hinten am Kristall einen Detektor, der Licht messen kann.
Und aus der Menge des Lichts, das dieser Detektor hinten am Kristall misst,
kann man dann rückschließen, wie viel Energie sozusagen dort deponiert wurde.
Und das heißt, man kann diese Messung mit der Messung aus dem Siliziumdetektor kombinieren.
Dieser Kristalldetektor ist auch notwendig, weil der Siliziumdetektor wird nur
elektrisch geladene Teilchen sehen.
Das heißt neutrale Teilchen, wie zum Beispiel Photonen, Lichtteilchen,
werden im Siliziumdetektor nicht gesehen.
Die werden erst dann in diesem Kristallteil gesehen werden.
Also wenn diese Kalorimeter, die dann auch die Endstation darstellen für die
auseinanderfliegenden Teilchen.
Wenn die jetzt zuverlässig aber eingefangen werden sollen, dann muss ja im Prinzip
eine riesige, vollständige, den kompletten zentralen Teil umschließende Schicht sein.
Das ist genau die Grundkonzeption. Wir wollen natürlich möglichst alle Teilchen
messen, die aus der Kollision entstehen. Das heißt wir möchten den Kollisionspunkt
eigentlich möglichst hermetisch umschließen.
Das ist nicht vollständig möglich, weil wir… Man muss ja auch mal ran, ne?
Naja, der Beschleuniger, die Beschleunigerröhre muss natürlich durchlaufen.
Das heißt, dort per Definition können keine Detektoren stehen,
aber wir versuchen den Rest möglichst abzudecken.
Und wie gesagt, nachdem wir mehrere Lagen verschiedene Detektoren brauchen,
sind die so angeordnet, dass ein Teilchen eben, egal in welche Richtung es läuft,
immer dieselbe Sequenz von Detektortypen durchläuft.
Und man könnte sich jetzt naiv vorstellen, dass man eine Kugel baut,
Aber das ist aus mechanischen, Wartungs- und ähnlichen Gründen nicht sehr praktisch.
Das heißt, die meisten dieser Experimente an Beschleunigern,
an Speicherringen wie dem LAC, haben einen zylindrischen Aufbau.
Das heißt, man hat einen zentralen Zylinder, in dem man eine zylindrische Lage nach der anderen hat.
Und das wird dann abgeschlossen durch Endkappen, also großen kreisförmigen Strukturen,
wo dieselbe Sequenz, aber linear von der Mitte nach außen, nach links und nach rechts geht.
Vorkommt und dadurch kann man den Detektor relativ leicht öffnen,
weil man kann diese Endcaps, wie wir es sagen, diese kreisförmigen Strukturen
vom Zentralteil entfernen und dann ins Innere des Detektors kommen.
Aber durch diesen Aufbau kann man garantieren, dass dieselbe Sequenz von Detektoren
von jedem Teich entgegen ist.
Das heißt, diese Kalorimeter, dieser Zylinder ist sozusagen komplett mit diesem
Blei, was war das für eine Verbindung?
Genau mit diesen Kristallen beschichtet und messen kann man das dann,
also das ist dann diese Sintillation, also das ist sozusagen so ein Lichteffekt
der dabei dann entsteht.
Genau es wird Licht erzeugt im Kristall und dieses Licht wird gemessen.
Okay also im Prinzip ist es dann letzten Endes ein optisches Messgerät,
was eigentlich das Licht misst.
Misst die Quantität von Licht die aus dem Kristall kommt.
Okay, gut. Und das tut es mit welcher Auflösung dann wiederum?
Also man kann ja nicht jeden Punkt beobachten.
Ja, wie gesagt, über die ganze Fläche. Wir haben jetzt hier 80.000 Kristalle.
Man muss sich vorstellen, die Kristalle sind so längliche Gebilde mit einem
quadratischen Querschnitt von einigen Zentimetern.
Okay, also 80.000 Kalometer.
Also die Größe ist dadurch bestimmt, dass die Schauer eine gewisse Ausdehnung
in der Tiefe, aber auch in der Breite haben.
Und es ist sinnlos, die Detektoren sozusagen sehr viel kleiner zu machen als
die Breite des Schauers. Das war die ursprüngliche Idee.
Das bestimmte die Zahl der Kristalle.
Und das ist der erste Teil des Kalorimeters. Und in diesem Teil,
der genügt, um de facto alle Teilchen zu stoppen, die elektromagnetisch wechselwirken,
also wir sind Elektronen und Photonen.
Und andere Teilchen, Hadronen, die erzeugen größere Schauer und wir brauchen
einen zweiten Kalorimeterteil dahinter.
Also die durchschlagen sozusagen auch noch diesen ersten Teil.
Genau, die würden zwar einen Schauer beginnen im ersten Teil,
aber der Schauer wäre so tief, dass er aus diesen Kristallen heraustritt und hinten raustritt.
Ohne einen Lichteffekt zu erzeugen?
Nein, es wird Licht erzeugt, aber das Problem ist, dass nicht der gesamte Schauer
enthalten sein wird in den Kristallen.
Das geht danach weiter und dann haben wir einen zweiten Teil.
Das beruhigt wieder auf dem Prinzip, dass wir dem Teilchen möglichst viel Material entgegenstellen.
Aber in dem Fall ist das Messing.
Es ist sozusagen ein Sandwich von Messing und wieder Zintillatoren.
Zintillatoren, das ist ein Plastikmaterial und dort ist wieder dieselbe Idee.
In dem Plastikmaterial entsteht Licht und man misst das Licht am Ende des Elements
und aus der Quantität des Lichts schließt man.
Das ist also auch nochmal so eine zylindrische Struktur.
Das generiert wieder eine zylindrische Struktur, die eben außerhalb des,
die nächste Lage darstellt nach diesen Kristallen.
Und wie viele Detektoren sind das dann?
Das ist in großen Modulen strukturiert. Also wir haben einige hundert von den
großen Modulen, aber in jedem Modul gibt es Glasfasern, die Teile des Moduls messen.
Ja, also ist das dann so wie bei dem ersten Zylinder, so 80.000 in der Größenordnung?
Es ist in der Größenordnung. In diesem Teil braucht man etwas weniger Genauigkeit.
Das heißt, man muss nicht so feine Elemente haben.
Gut, nur mal so ein Gefühl für die Datenpunkte zu bekommen, wie viel das so ist.
Und dann gibt es einen...
Gibt es noch Teilchen, die diese Schicht dann auch noch überwinden können?
Genau, dann gibt es die berühmten Myonern, die diese Schicht überwinden können.
Ah ja, okay, jetzt wird es spannend.
Diese Myonen sind eingelagert, diese Detektoren sind eingelagert in dieses Rückflussjoch.
Also ich habe davon gesprochen, dass wir das Magnetfeld sozusagen im Detektor
zu halten, haben wir diese Stahlkonstruktion, die rundherum geht.
Und in diese Stahlkonstruktion sind eingelagert, in Spalten in der Stahlkonstruktion
sind Myonkammern eingelagert. Und in dem Fall sind das Gasdetektoren.
Das sind Detektoren, Schichten mit verschiedenen Technologien,
die mit einem Gas gefüllt sind.
Wenn Teilchen durch das Gas durchlaufen, dann ionisieren sie Atome in dem Gas
und man kann diese Ladungen durch elektrische Felder bewegen und dann messen.
Diese Detektoren werden elektronisch ausgelesen, also de facto die Bewegung
dieser Ladungen der Elektronen und der positiven Ionen, die dabei entstehen,
die erzeugen elektrische Signale auf Elektroden und die werden dann ausgelesen.
Dort ist es eben wichtig, dass wir mit vernünftigen Kosten eine sehr,
sehr große Fläche abdecken können, In diesem Prinzip, dass eine Lage nach der
anderen kommt, natürlich je weiter man nach außen kommt, desto größer wird die
Fläche, die man abdecken muss. Gleichzeitig ist die,
ist die Genauigkeit, die man dort erzielen muss, geringer.
Das heißt, dort genügt uns ein Zehntel Millimeter oder etwas weniger.
Und der Grund dafür ist, dass die Myonen, bis sie in diese Lage kommen,
haben sie schon viel Material durchlaufen. Das Material wird sie zwar nicht
stoppen, aber es wird leichte Ablenkung an der Bahn verursachen.
Und das heißt, es ist sinnlos genauer zu messen als die typische Größenordnung
dieser Ablenkung der Bahn.
Zu den Myonen möchte ich vielleicht noch sagen, dass im Prinzip,
so wie die CMS konzipiert wurde, um die Myoner zu messen, um zu wissen,
dass es ein Myon ist, brauchen wir dieses Signal in den äußersten Detektorschichten.
Aber die genaue Messung der Energie des Muons wird in CMS gemacht,
dass wir den inneren Siliziumdetektor mit den Informationen aus diesen Muonsdetektoren verbinden.
Das erklärt jetzt auch warum dieser Muon, also warum das auch im Namen drinsteckt.
Weil es sozusagen ein Element in diesem großen Magnet mit drin ist und von daher
sozusagen so ein Major Design Prinzip darstellt sozusagen und nicht einfach
nur so ein bisschen Gerät, was man noch in die Mitte reingeworfen hat.
Also dieser Teilchen zu diesem Standardmodell ist ja wirklich...
Das kann ja sehr verwirrend sein. Was wir ja die ganze Zeit angerissen haben mit diesen Myonen.
Es gibt ja in diesem Standardmodell Klassifizierungen auf unterschiedlichen Dimensionen.
Wenn man erstmal generell so diese Quarks und Leptoden unterscheidet,
also das was sozusagen Protonen im wesentlichen baut sind die Quarks und der
Rest sind eben die Elektronen und Verwandte sozusagen.
Gibt es ja das dann alles noch dreimal.
Alles ist irgendwie dreimal vorhanden, hat dann andere Namen,
ähnliche Namen und warum es das jetzt alles dreimal gibt, weiß man nicht so
richtig und es gibt es dreimal, weil es dann unterschiedliche Massen hat.
Das ist ganz klar eine der großen unbeantworteten Fragen in der Teilchenphysik,
dass man im Moment keine Erklärung hat, warum es drei Generationen sein sollten.
Diese Teilchen haben exakt die gleichen Eigenschaften, nur die Masse ist unterschiedlich. Genau.
Das heißt dieses Myon, von dem wir jetzt die ganze Zeit reden,
um das mal ein bisschen bekannter zu machen, ist eigentlich in seinem Wesen ein Elektron.
Es ist nur sehr viel schwerer als ein Elektron.
In welchem Faktor ist das schwerer, sehr viel schwerer?
200 Faktor, 1000, 2000, ca.
2000. Ca. 2000 sind 500 Kiloelektronvolt und 100 Megelektronvolt.
Ja, wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall ist sehr viel schwerer, aber ist ansonsten wie so.
Warum gibt's da, also das wissen wir nicht, aber warum ist man da jetzt so drauf abgefahren?
200 Stimmen.
Genau, aber es gibt ja auch noch ein drittes, was dann nochmal extrem viel schwerer
ist, das ist dann das Tauon.
Genau, das Tauon oder Taulepton.
Das sieht man aber nicht.
Oh ja, das produzieren wir ebenfalls.
Kann das auch detektiert werden?
Natürlich, wir detektieren das. Das einzige Problem, es ist schwerer zu detektieren,
das Elektronen und Myonen, weil es nämlich relativ instabil ist.
Elektronen sind stabile Teilchen, da gibt es kein Problem.
Myonen zerfallen, aber die Lebensdauer eines Myons ist so groß,
dass sie auf jeden Fall den Detektor verlassen werden, bevor sie zerfallen.
Dagegen haben Daunen, eben weil sie schwer sind, eine relativ kurze Lebenszeit.
Und das heißt, die würden schon in den ersten Zentimetern des Detektors zerfallen.
Das heißt wir werden kein Dow-Lapton als solches durch den Detektor fliegen sehen,
sondern das Dow-Lapton kann in verschiedene Konfigurationen zerfallen und um
die Dow-Laptonen zu identifizieren müssen wir eben die Sekundärteilchen,
in die das Dow-Lapton zerfallen ist, identifizieren.
Also man weiß schon, dass es da war, aber man sieht es nicht als sollte so.
Es ist schwieriger zu sehen, ja.
Ok, verstehe. Und warum ist man dann jetzt so scharf drauf?
Also was kann man, was meint man oder was kann man denn sozusagen daraus ableiten,
dass jetzt sozusagen dieses Myon da ist?
Ja, wie gesagt, eine direkte Erklärung, warum es eben diese drei Generationen gibt, haben wir nicht.
Aber das, wie gesagt, unser derzeitiges Standardmodell,
mathematisches Modell, mit dem wir die Teilchen und die Kräfte zwischen den
Teilchen beschreiben, setzt eben voraus, dass sich diese drei Generationen gleich
verhalten, bis auf die Masse.
Und das ist zum Beispiel ein interessanter Teil des Forschungsgebietes,
um zu überprüfen, möglichst gut zu überprüfen, ob das wirklich der Fall ist.
Weil wenn es nicht der Fall wäre, das würde das Ansatz geben,
um neue Theorien zu entwickeln.
Und deswegen, das ist natürlich ein Grund, sie zu messen. Der andere Grund,
sie zu messen, ist, dass es einfach zusätzliche Möglichkeiten gibt,
um andere Teilchen zu vermessen oder zu entdecken.
Weil sehr oft, eben dadurch, dass die Elektronen Myon und Olepton dieselben
Eigenschaften haben, kann ein Teilchen, das in Elektronen zerfallen kann oder
in Myonen zerfallen kann, auch in die jeweils anderen Teilchen zerfallen.
Das heißt, wir können dieses zerfallende Teilchen genau untersuchen.
Wir haben mehr Möglichkeiten, wenn wir alle drei Zerfallsmodi untersuchen.
Old Myon spielt auch eine Rolle bei der Detektion des Higgs-Bosons?
Zum Beispiel, ja.
Genau, das Higgs-Boson kann in sehr viele unterschiedliche Arten zerfallen.
Und eine dieser Arten ist, dass es de facto zuerst in zwei Z-Posonen,
das sind die Vermittler der schwachen Wechselwirkung übrigens, zerfällt.
Und diese Posonen können dann wieder in Leptonen zerfallen, zum Beispiel.
Auch in Quarks, aber sie können auch in Leptonen zerfallen.
Und sie können zum Beispiel in zwei Myonen zerfallen. Es könnte jedes dieser
zwei Z-Posonen dann in zwei Myonen zerfallen.
Und warum uns das besonders interessiert, ist einfach, weil wir die Myonen,
das ist wirklich das Objekt, das wir am besten messen können.
Sie können auch in Detektoren zerfallen, andere Teilchen, aber der Zerfall in
insgesamt vier Myonen ist das, was wir normalerweise einen goldenen Kanal nennen.
Das heißt, das ist wirklich die Art und Weise, die wir am besten messen können.
Ah ja, okay, verstehe.
Voraussetzung ist natürlich, dass wir alle vier Myonen in einer Zone des Detektors
sind, die wir sehen können.
Und warum ist es wichtig, dass man die so genau messen kann,
ist, weil wir dann aus den, wenn wir die Energien und Richtungen der Virmionen
bestimmen, können wir zurückrechnen, die Masse des Teilchens, die zerfallen ist.
Das ist, wie wir überhaupt versuchen, typischerweise neue Teilchen zu finden.
Es gibt Energiehaltung, d.h. wenn ein schweres Teilchen zerfällt,
muss die Masse, also Masse und Energie der Zerfallsprodukte,
aus denen kann man wieder die Masse des ursprünglichen Teilchens zurückrechnen.
Und man sollte sagen, am LHC, wir haben immer sehr viel...
Untergrund. Das heißt, wir suchen ein bestimmtes Ereignis, einen bestimmten
Typ von Ereignis, aber es gibt immer andere Prozesse, die etwas Ähnliches produzieren.
Aber dadurch, dass wir diese Masse rekonstruieren können, ist dieser Untergrund,
der ist normalerweise einfach zufällig verteilt.
Und wenn es wirklich ein neues Teilchen ist, wie das X-Boson im Jahr 2012,
dann sehen wir, dann werden die berechneten Massen, werden immer dort an der
echten Masse des neuen Teilchens sitzen.
Das heißt, wenn wir das ansehen, dann gibt es eben diesen Untergrund,
der verteilt ist und über diesem Untergrund werden wir beginnen ein Signal zu
sehen, dass auf einer bestimmten Stelle immer mehr Ereignisse sind,
die genau diesen Wert haben.
Das ist wie das X-Boson gefunden wurde und das ist auch die Methode,
um nach anderen Teilchen zu suchen.
Genau, weil am Ende ist es ja alles eine statistische Betrachtung,
jede Kollision ist anders, immer wieder passiert irgendwas,
aber mit einer bestimmten Wahrscheinlichkeit passieren halt bestimmte Dinge
häufiger und wenn man das dann eben einfach über Wochen,
Monate und Milliarden an Beobachtungen zusammensummiert und plottet,
dann entstehen halt diese Grafiken, wo so eine kleine Spitze ist,
die halt so einen ganzen Raum voller Wissenschaftler total zum Schreien bringen,
weil das dann einfach total irre ist.
Und alle anderen fragen sich nur so, was passiert hier eigentlich gerade?
Aber das kennt man ja auch aus anderen Sportarten. Also Leute,
die mit Fußball nichts zu tun haben, wundern sich ja dann auch mal wieder,
was die anderen alle so begeistert.
Ja, aber etwas zu finden, was man 60 Jahre lang gesucht hat,
das kann etwas Begeisterung auslösen. Genau.
Jetzt kommen wir vielleicht so langsam zum Ende und die große Frage ist ja halt immer,
wie kann das alles dazu beitragen jetzt auch wirklich was neues zu finden und
vielleicht neu ist ja dann auch immer so ein dehnbarer Begriff,
also das Higgs Boson war ja nicht in dem Sinne neu, als dass es auf einmal so
da war und man gesagt, oh Holla was ist das denn?
Sondern das war ja quasi eine Suche nach 60 Jahren, weil es eben diese Theorie
gab, wenn es das gäbe, dann würde auf einmal alles zusammenpassen.
Alles was wir bisher beobachtet haben, haben wir sozusagen in dieses Standardmodell
eingefügt, da fehlte dann aber irgendwie noch so ein Slot und man hat immer
so gehofft, dass es das auch gibt, weil dann passt alles zusammen,
weil wenn es das nicht gibt, dann passt gar nichts mehr zusammen.
Dann müsste man sich was Neues ausdenken und bisher ist noch keinem was anderes eingefallen.
Naja es gibt einige andere Ansätze, aber es war klar der einfachste Ansatz um
das zu finden und deswegen war es spannend um zu sehen ob dieser Ansatz auch
wirklich realistisch ist.
Ich denke es ist ja auch alles gebaut worden. Deswegen hat man den LAC gebaut,
deswegen hat man diese Energien versucht aufzubauen,
weil man halt einfach so ein gewisses Target hat und sagt okay das ist so der
Energiebedarf den wir benötigen und wenn wir das dann lange genug beobachten,
dann haben wir vielleicht eben diese Auffälligkeit und CMS ist einer von den
beiden Detektoren, die das eben mit der hier beschriebenen Technik beobachtet
haben, die Statistiken gemacht hat.
Atlas das andere, was im Prinzip dasselbe in grün gemacht hat und dann werden
wir halt auch nochmal drüber reden, wie das dort funktioniert und der Vergleich
dieser beiden Ergebnisse hat dann eben diese Gewissheit gebracht.
So jetzt ist das aber sozusagen aus dem Rennen, Higgs ist jetzt alter Käse.
Absolut nicht.
Es wird natürlich nach wie vor noch weiter geguckt nach Higgs oder?
Wir stehen eigentlich am Anfang der Reise, weil Entdeckung heißt,
dass wir die ersten überzeugenden Zeichen für die Existenz eines Teilchens gefunden haben.
Aber was jetzt gemacht wird, ist zu überprüfen, was wir wissen.
Wir haben ein Teilchen gefunden. Das Teilchen entspricht in etwa den Erwartungen der Theorie.
Aber was wir jetzt machen ist, um die detaillierten Vorhersagen der Theorie
zu überprüfen und zu sehen, ob dieses
Higgs-Teilchen wirklich genau das Higgs-Teilchen dieses Modells ist.
Und das ist eben ein langfristiges Programm.
Das Higgs-Feld gibt eben Masse an die Teilchen und das hängt damit zusammen,
wie stark sozusagen diese Teilchen mit dem Higgs-Boson reden. und.
Das bedingt auch, wie oft ein Higgs-Boson aus diesen Teilchen erzeugt werden
kann oder wie oft ein Higgs-Boson in diese Teilchen zerfallen wird.
Und die Vorhersage des Standard-Modells, dieses Modells ist eben,
dass diese Wechselwirkung immer schwächer wird, je leichter Teilchen werden.
Und dementsprechend werden die leichteren Teilchen auch seltener im Zerfall
eines Higgs-Bosons vorkommen.
Und die Entdeckung des X-Bosons wurde im Wesentlichen getragen durch den Zerfall
in zwei Arten, eben in zwei Z-Bosonen oder ein Zerfall in zwei Photonen.
Jetzt kann man sich fragen, Sie haben gesagt, dass das X hängt mit Masse zusammen.
Das X gibt eigentlich die Masse. Photonen sind bekannterweise masselos.
Also wie kann ein Higgs-Boson in Photonen zerfallen? Und das geschieht in der Beschreibung,
die wir von der Natur in der Quantenfeldtheorie haben, dass da einfach ein komplizierter
Prozess aufgetreten ist, dass das Higgs ursprünglich in zwei andere Teilchen
zerfallen ist und diese Teilchen dann zwei Photonen erzeugt haben.
Und in Wirklichkeit hängt das sehr stark zusammen mit dem zerfallen SIX-Bosons
in zwei virtuelle Topquarks, also in schwere Teilchen.
Und im Prinzip haben wir jetzt gemessen und wir haben überzeugende Messungen,
dass der SIX eben in Z-Bosonen zerfallen kann,
in W-Bosonen zerfallen kann, dass der SIX mit Topquarks redet,
dass der SIX, also direkt in Topquarks, in zwei Topquarks kann der SIX nicht
zerfallen, weil der SIX einfach zu leicht ist.
Die zwei Top Quarks zusammen werden schwerer als das X-Poson und deswegen kann
es nicht direkt zerfallen.
Aber es kann trotzdem in der Produktion und im Zerfall auf indirekte Arten mit
diesen Top Quarks reden.
Wir haben den Zerfall in B, Quarks.
Und die berühmten Dow-Leptonen. Das sind alles de facto die schwersten Teilchen, die wir kennen.
Aber um jetzt überzeugt zu sein, dass dieser Mechanismus der Stärke der Wechselwirkung
mit Masse wirklich funktioniert, sollten wir auch sehen, ob es mit den leichteren Teilchen redet.
Und wir haben jetzt in CMS, wir haben mit den Daten aus den letzten Jahren das
erste Mal einen Hinweis dafür gesehen, dass das X-Boson direkt in zwei Myonen zerfallen kann.
Das ist schon jetzt ein großer Sprung in der Masse, weil, wie schon gesagt wurde,
die Myonen sind sehr viel leichter als die Dauleptonen zum Beispiel,
auch sehr viel leichter als Z-Bosonen oder W-Bosonen. Das heißt,
da ist ein großer Sprung.
Wir haben eben Hinweise dafür, noch nicht auf dem Niveau,
das wir typischerweise in der gleichen Physik Entdeckungsniveau nennen,
diese berühmten 5 Sigma statistische Wahrscheinlichkeit, also Wahrscheinlichkeit
von weniger als 1 zu 1 Million, dass das einfach eine Fluktuation war.
Aber das steht auf unserem Programm und auch zur Fälle in andere leichte Teilchen,
um eben das vollkommen zu überprüfen, das Modell.
Und dann auf einer etwas längeren Zeitskala ist die Frage, wie das Higgs mit
sich selbst redet und...
Teilchen reden auch mit sich selbst.
Ja, es kann ein Higgs-Boson zum Beispiel in zwei Higgs-Bosonen zerfallen und
zwei Higgs-Bosonen produzieren in seinem Zerfall.
Und das Interessante daran ist, dass das Higgs-Boson ursprünglich erfunden wurde,
um zu erklären, warum diese W- und Z-Bosonen, für die es in den 80er Jahren
den Nobelpreis gegeben hat und die die schwache Wechselwirkung erklären,
warum die nicht wie das Photon masselos sind, sondern warum sie eine Masse haben,
eine ziemlich hohe Masse sogar.
Und das läuft unter dem Konzept der Symmetriebrechung.
Es gibt da in Symmetrienstellen einen sehr wichtigen Bestandteil aller modernen
Theorien der Teilchenphysik vor.
Symmetrien können so etwas wie die einfache Links-Rechts-Spiegelsymmetrie sein,
die wir kennen, aber es kann auch Symmetrien in anderen Formen geben,
die zum Beispiel, das wäre sozusagen eine Art Spiegeleffekt,
die zum Beispiel ein Teilchen in ein anderes Teilchen verwandeln könnte und
dadurch ihre Ähnlichkeit erklärt.
Und jedenfalls, das Higgs-Poson hat eben diese spezielle Eigenschaft,
Eigenschaft, dass es eine gewisse Symmetrie bricht, also dazu führt,
dass die Symmetrie nicht mehr vollkommen respektiert wird.
Und das gibt diesen W- und Z-Posonen die Masse.
Und das hängt sehr stark davon zusammen, eben wie stark dieses X-Poson sozusagen mit sich selbst redet.
Und das ist ein Programm, das ist sehr schwierig zu messen. Das ist ein Prozess,
der noch viel seltener ist, als was wir im Moment schon messen und die,
Und das wird wirklich ein Programm sein für die nächsten Jahre,
für die zukünftige Phase des LACs und dann sogar, wahrscheinlich um Präzise
zu messen, auch für die nächste Beschleuniger-Generation, die nachher kommen werden.
Okay, also man ist quasi auf der Mission, also nachdem man sich sicher war,
dass Higgs-Prinzip das existiert, das ist da, das ist messbar,
das entspricht so gut den Vorhersagen und wir haben es auch aus den statistischen
Daten mit der statistischen Sicherheit herauslesen können.
Da ist was, geht es jetzt im Wesentlichen darum zu sagen, wie verhält es sich
jetzt genau, was hat das für eine Auswirkung.
Das ist jetzt sehr kompliziert zu verstehen, dieser ganze Bereich.
Aber eine Sache wollte ich mal kurz rausgreifen, weil das irgendwie eben viel,
also wenn wir jetzt den Begriff Wechselwirkung hier mit reinnehmen,
hab ich ja vorhin schon auch angesprochen, da haben wir es ja sozusagen mit
diesen Naturkräften zu tun.
Schwache Kernkraft durch diese WZ-Versionen, die elektromagnetische Kraft durch dieses Photon,
die starke Kernkraft durch diese Gluon, die dann halt irgendwie Lepton und Quark
irgendwie zusammenbacken oder auch nicht. Und...
Dann gibt's halt noch dieses Higgs. Und jetzt hast du aber auch diesen Begriff
Wechselwirkung in den Mund genommen, wenn man sagt, wie Higgs jetzt sozusagen
mit den anderen interagiert.
Heißt das, dass man dann sozusagen, also ist das dann sozusagen noch eine weitere
Kraft, die wir so bisher so nicht auf dem Zeiger haben oder reden wir jetzt
hier von einer anderen Wirkung, die nicht auf dem Level sich abspielt?
Ich würde das nicht als Kraft bezeichnen. Es ist einfach nur,
dass es Prozesse gibt, in denen Higgs-Boson und andere Teilchen vorkommen und
die dann… Also nicht jede Wechselwirkung ist eine Kraft, aber jede Kraft ist eine Wechselwirkung?
Ja, das könnte man vielleicht so sagen.
Aber was man vielleicht zum Programm mit dem Higgs-Boson noch hinzufügen sollte,
ist, dass das Higgs-Boson auch sehr interessant ist, um mögliche neue Effekte zu studieren.
Wir haben noch nicht erwähnt, dass das Standardmodell, dass wir sehr zufrieden
sind, dass wir dieses letzte Teilchen des Standardmodells gefunden haben.
Aber wir wissen, dass es nicht vollständig sein kann.
Und da gibt es einen starken Zusammenhang mit Kosmologie und dem,
was wir im Universum beobachten, weil zwei der großen Fragen in der Entwicklung des Universums sind,
warum es einen Unterschied zwischen Teilchen und Antiteilchen gibt und was es
mit dieser berühmten dunklen Materie im Universum an sich hat.
Und beide Themenbereiche hängen mit Teilchenphysik zusammen,
weil der Unterschied zwischen Teilchen und Antiteilchen,
das ist etwas, was man messen kann in verschiedenen Arten, auch am LHC,
Und die dunkle Materie, es ist sehr plausibel, dass die dunkle Materie de facto
aus Teilchen besteht, die wir noch nicht kennen.
Und wo kommt das Higgs da hinein? In vielen theoretischen Modellen,
die versuchen, dunkle Materie mit neuen Teilchen zu erklären,
spielt das Higgs-Boson oder mehrere, möglicherweise mehrere andere Higgs-Bosonen noch eine Rolle,
um sozusagen die Welt, die wir da jetzt schon kennen, und diese dunkle Welt
miteinander zu verbinden, also Verbindungen herzustellen zwischen den Teilchen, die wir kennen,
und der Produktion von Teilchen, die wir noch nicht können und die zum Beispiel
dunkle Materie hervorrufen könnten.
Also zum Beispiel würde man jetzt, und das ist ja unter anderem auch geplant,
noch einen größeren Ring bauen und damit noch mehr Energien aufbauen können
und noch fettere Detektoren bauen,
die mit diesen Energien auch umgehen, was dann noch größere Magneten wären und
überhaupt kann man sich das fast schon gar nicht mehr vorstellen,
Wie groß das alles wäre, auf jeden Fall wenn man sozusagen höhere Energien noch beobachten könnte,
dann könnte es vielleicht theoretisch sein, dass auch in der Mangelung einer
passenden Theorie zu diesem Zeitpunkt mal halt an irgendeiner Stelle mit noch
mehr Energien nochmal so einen kleinen Hopser in der Kurve hat.
Das muss nicht unbedingt beim nächsten, das könnte natürlich beim nächsten Beschleuniger
sein, aber selbst bei uns könnten Prozesse sein, die einfach so selten sind.
Die einfach selten sind, das ist der andere Punkt. Oder aber eben auch,
dass man erstmal woanders noch suchen muss, das meinte ich eigentlich mehr.
Also es könnte auch sein, dass man nochmal ganz woanders gucken muss,
als wir derzeit gucken können und dort sozusagen nochmal so ein Geschwisterhicks haben,
die dann vielleicht einfach nur in der Antimaterie irgendwas machen und da diese
Massen erzeugen, die wir quasi da ja ausmachen.
Weil das ist ja das, was wir sehen. Wir sehen, dass da irgendwas gravitativ wirkt,
Galaxien irgendwie zusammenhält und auf andere Geschwindigkeiten bringt,
die sich eben mit unserer Vorstellung der normalen Materie nicht verbinden lässt
und von daher irgendwie das große Fragezeichen, also eins der großen drei Fragezeichen
ist, die wir derzeit so im Weltall haben.
Ja, aber die Verteilung von dunkler Materie und die Geschichte des Universums
sagt uns, dass es eine gewisse Verbindung, eine sehr, sehr schwache Verbindung,
aber zwischen diesen Teilchen, wenn es Teilchen sind der dunklen Materie,
und den normalen Teilchen geben sollte.
Und das ist eben Teil des Forschungsprogramms. Mit dieser Verbindung könnten
wir diese Teilchen unter Umständen hier auch schon im LHC produzieren und mit dem Detektor sehen.
Das ist übrigens ein interessanter Aspekt, dass die Detektoren de facto auch
Deichen Detektieren können, die gar nicht direkt im Detektorsignal hinterlassen.
Man kann etwas detektieren, was man gar nicht detektiert?
Genau, das betrifft schon bekannte Teilchen.
Im Standardmodell mit den Elektronen, das Elektron hat nicht nur schwere Geschwister,
sondern auch ein Pendant, das ist das Neutrino, das zum Beispiel in großen Mengen
in der Sonne in den Kernprozessen erzeugt wird.
Und das Neutrino ist fast masselos und hat nur eine sehr schwache Wechselwirkung mit Materie.
Das heißt, die Neutrinos würden aus unseren Detektoren hinauslaufen und wir
würden sie nicht sehen. Aber auch wenn wir zum Beispiel Teilchen der dunklen
Materie erzeugen könnten, würden diese auch den Detektor verlassen, ohne dass wir sie sehen.
Aber wir können uns ein Prinzip in der Physik zunutze machen,
und das ist, es gibt die Energieerhaltung, aber es gibt auch ein Prinzip,
das nennt sich Impulserhaltung, das ist also, sagen wir so, verwandt mit der
Energie, aber das spielt sich in allen drei Raumrichtungen ab.
Das heißt, man kennt vielleicht dieses Spiel mit dem Bändeln mit den Kugeln,
wo man die Kugel fallen lässt und dann läuft auf der anderen Seite eine Kugel
raus. Das ist de facto Impulserhaltung und das könnte man auch in drei Dimensionen machen.
Jedenfalls, wir haben das Prinzip, dass die Protonen, die zusammenlaufen,
die bewegen sich entlang des Beschleunigers, auf einer geraden Linie eben,
aber nicht links, rechts, oben und unten.
Und daraus schließt man, dass die Summe aller Teilchen, die nach der Kollision
produziert wird, kann insgesamt, kollektiv sozusagen, auch keine Bewegung links,
rechts, oben und unten haben.
Und wenn da jetzt aber ein Teilchen dabei wäre mit hoher Energie,
das wir nicht sehen, Und wir machen die Summe über alle sichtbaren Teilchen
und würden sehen, dass die Summe der sichtbaren Teilchen in irgendeine Richtung zeigen würde.
Während das unsichtbare Teilchen in die andere Richtung gegangen wäre.
Und auf diese Art und Weise können wir feststellen, ob ein unsichtbares Teilchen
den Detektor verlassen hat.
Also man rechnet sozusagen einfach nach wie viel Energie ist denn hier insgesamt
fehlt, was fehlt, fehlt und daraus kann man schließen.
Und damit könnte man zum Beispiel sehen, falls dunkle Materie produziert würde
und das ist ein wichtiger Teil unseres Forschungsprogramms.
Ja, spannend. Das bringt uns jetzt so ein bisschen ans Ende.
Können natürlich jetzt noch stundenlang weiter philosophieren,
aber um es vielleicht mal abzurunden.
Man sieht, dass die Detektoren halt auf der einen Seite dazu beitragen,
bestehende Theorien zu überprüfen und das eben teilweise mit Erfolg,
aber auch das nicht Nachweisen ist ja in gewisser Hinsicht auch ein Erfolg,
aber auch noch sehr viel Potenzial hat jetzt sozusagen auf dem nächsten Weg
mit der existierenden Technologie plus der Upgrades, die ja hier regelmäßig
stattfinden, die halt Dinge genauer machen, verfeinern, Energien erhöhen usw.
Anders ballen, dass man eben auch auf dem Pfad zu weiteren Erkenntnissen kommen kann.
Also jetzt nicht mit dem Higgs ist nicht das ganze Pulver verschossen worden. Nein, absolut.
Und wie gesagt, wenn man ein neues Teilchen entdeckt, das ist die erste Stufe,
die ist Entdeckung und die zweite Stufe ist dann, um dieses neue Teilchen de
facto als Werkzeug zu verwenden, um neue Erkenntnisse zu bekommen.
Ja, gut Wolfgang, ich sag vielen Dank für die Ausführung zum CMS,
das war alles sehr interessant, sehr spannend.
Ja, und ich bedanke mich fürs Zuhören, das war's zum CMS, weiter geht's dann
mit dem Atlas, gucken wir mal wie die auf die Welt schauen, ja.
Und dann geht's halt hier wieder weiter. Bis dann sagt Tschüss, bis bald!